point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note the meeting will be audio
recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
members there is a need to use
microphones during this meeting
when i invite you to speak
please speak clearly into the microphone
in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording members can you all hear
me
thank you
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution i
will ask for a show of hands
for
and then against and recommendations
will also be asked for a show of hands
for those wishing to abstain from voting
please keep your hands uh
up until we our song is counted and then
we can have them
uh taken down thank you
got two minutes until half past and then
we'll start the meeting in full thank
you
people who want to speak will be asked
to come and sit next to
katie fowler so everyone there's a
microphone there so everyone will be
able to hear you thank you thank you
for the meeting to start can i ask if
you've read
all read your papers and also send the
addendum to item six seven
bracket one eight to nine please and
have you all read them
thank you
rid of this
one minute
as
we have apologies for absence
uh we have received apologies for
absence from councillors who will be
substituted by councillor
mrs wilson
councillor mason will be substituted by
councillor hawaii
councillor milne will be substituted by
councillor belton
and apologies have also been received by
councillor knight and councillor lawman
um
council lawman will be substituted by
council loan bob
yeah
council knight will be substituted
right sorry it's the other way around
sorry councillor knight will be
substituted by councillor
lambong welcome to the new members of
the committee
we have none um
non-members attending we've got
councillor cross councillor knights
councillor rot
she's not here as she counselor i'm
sorry councillor and councillor woodson
have i missed any members
non-members no thank you
members minutes of the meeting held on
the 21st of april 2022 are they agreed
please
thank you
to receive declarations of interest item
five
as i campaigned against it when i was a
resident a long time ago
is that okay
okay i didn't know right okay thank you
i members item six
lane north of london road west of roarth
industrial state rorth lane rayleigh and
i believe it's
katie rogers who will do the
presentation thank you
can you is that on
thank you chairman
chairman this application relates to two
parcels of
land it just be reminded to officers
that i'd come
thank you
chairman this application relates to two
parcels of land at a site known as land
north of london road it's also now known
as the woolsey park site
the parcels subject to this application
are either side of the spine road so
they're shown edged red on the screen
but
to assist members i will just outline
them here so there's um one parcel here
over towards the eastern side of the
spine road and then opposite on the
western side of the spine road here
these parcels are part of a wider site
which is subject to outline planning
permission for largely residential
development
the principle of residential development
of this site has therefore already been
accepted and this application seeks
reserve matters consent relating to the
layout scale appearance and appearance
of the proposed dwellings and the
landscaping and access arrangements
in total 91 dwellings are proposed and
the plan on screen shows how
the buildings will be positioned
the majority of the dwellings are
two-story houses although some flats are
also included so if i just
zoom in slightly to this plan
so on this
western parcel here you've got this um
building here this one here and this one
here so they're flooded blocks on the
western parcel and then on the eastern
parcel there is a flooded block here
here
here and then towards the southern
boundary
the flats would be in two-story
buildings which would be similar in
scale and formed to some of the detached
dwellings proposed on the site
a mix of detached and semi-detached
houses are proposed and in the eastern
parcel several rows of terrorist houses
are proposed so you'll see um there's a
short row of four terraces here one here
and then if i just scroll
there's also one facing part of the
north northern boundary here
dwellings are positioned such that they
would face onto the roads so onto the
main spine road so all of these
dwellings along here would face onto the
spine road
these dwellings along the northern
boundary of the eastern parcel would
face onto the main street that's in the
adjacent parcel
and similarly on the western parcel
these dwellings here would face onto the
spine road
and these dwellings here would face onto
the area of open space provided on the
northern
part of that site
this layout would also ensure that
public green spaces would benefit from
passive surveillance from windows and
facing onto spaces which would help to
ensure that these are safe so that
includes the area of green space to be
provided within the site but also these
dwellings
that would face the eastern boundary all
have windows which you'll see from the
street scene i'll show in a minute
onto this area of open space to be
provided along the eastern corridor
the same is also true
of
the western
strategic open space so dwellings here
would also have windows facing onto this
space here
in terms of the relationship of the
dwellings proposed to one another it is
considered that this would be acceptable
both in terms of separation distance and
positioning of windows where dwellings
would occupy corner plots care has been
taken to ensure that side elevations
would also face a street frontage so for
example this dwelling here um so you
have the the front elevation facing
northward but you also have fenestration
to this side and that happens
throughout where dwellings are on corner
plots and there are quite a lot of them
throughout
all dwellings would benefit from an
enclosed rear garden and parking
provision some dwellings would also
feature garage spaces but this would be
in addition to two driveway parking
spaces
all driveway parking spaces would meet
the council's preferred bay size and
visitor parking would also be proposed
across both parcels
pedestrian links through the parcels
would link to pedestrian footpaths in
the adjacent areas of public open green
space so on this western parcel you've
got this area of open space and there
would be pedestrian footpaths through
which would link then to pedestrian
footpaths within the
wider strategic open green space you'd
also have a link through here into this
adjacent residential development parcel
there
and on the eastern parcel
the layout incorporates
pedestrian links through here so that
would not only benefit residents of of
this
part of the site but also
in the adjacent development parcel here
so they can link through to the green
space along the eastern boundary which
further south will eventually lead to
youth facilities
and
other parts of the development to the
south there's also a green a pedestrian
footpath here and another link here
through to that space there
roots would be logically positioned to
allow for good connectivity and then
hopefully encourage good use of this
surrounding green space
the western development parcel would
have a vehicular access from the south
so this point here and the eastern
parcel would utilize this existing um or
this vehicular access um that's part of
the reserve matters approval already
for this adjacent
uh residential parcel
here
so there's two so that one and this one
would be the vehicular accesses to the
site
both vehicle accesses already benefit
from reserve matters consent
both parcels would feature one main
street and you'll see that along part of
this
street here you'd have a pedestrian
footwear and then that would lead to a
shared surface area of street further
north and on off this a series of
private drives and another shared
surface street
a similar sort of arrangement
in this eastern parcel so you have the
main street
with
formal pedestrian footways either side
and that would link around a long part
of the eastern boundary
towards the southern boundary and this
vehicle access point here would provide
access to the future development parcel
and this benefits from outline planning
consent for commercial development
the focal square in the eastern parcel
here would provide a sort of distinct
area or character area within the
development
with a series of vehicle parking spaces
interspersed with tree planting and
there'll be different surfacing material
to give this a distinctive character
if i show you now some of the street
scenes
so a number of different house types are
proposed some of which are very similar
or the same as house types approved for
use in the adjacent um phase that's the
the phase adjacent to um the eastern
parcel
of this scheme
street scene b so that's this one in the
center here
shows the two-story scale of most of the
houses proposed and the houses would be
of traditional form with hipped or
gabled roofs and would be finished in a
mix of brick and render the rendered
houses in this image are to corner plots
and members will note the bay features
to these elevations so these aren't the
front elevations but these are the
elevations that would also have a
frontage onto the street because they're
cited on corner plots
street scene a at the top of the screen
would feature to the eastern boundary um
this is very um small this layout plan
but so it's the eastern boundary of the
eastern parcel so it's this street scene
that would look onto the open green
space along the eastern boundary
and this is the area of the site which
exhibits perhaps the greatest slope to
the existing ground levels so the
highest point of the site being in the
northeastern corner and then gradually
sloping
downwards to the south
plots 21 and 22 and 25 and 26 are
this plot here and this plot here and
there either side of the main street
which would be through the eastern
parcel
and these are
examples of the flatted buildings so the
buildings that would contain the flats
and you'll see that the scale of them is
is not dissimilar um to the to the
housing that's provided on the site
in those flatted buildings you get one
flat at ground floor and one above at
first floor
so street c h which is um this one here
um
shows the proposed house types to the
northern boundary of the eastern parcel
and it shows the only um two and a half
story property here which features those
are small dormer windows in the front
elevation
street scene g to the top of the screen
shows examples of the boundary
treatments proposed which would be brick
so where boundary treatments are
significant in length and very visible
in the public realm they're proposed in
a brick finish as opposed to the
boundary treatments between plots
and rear gardens which would be close
body fencing
so this plan on screen shows the
position of affordable housing so the
scheme would deliver 35 affordable
housing as is required by the outline
planning consent
and a mix of rented and shared ownership
which is denoted by the the red and blue
shading on this plan
the scale form and appearance of the
affordable houses would be similar to
some of the market houses within the
scheme and the same mix of external
facing materials would also be proposed
such that they wouldn't be
obviously differentiated
so this is one of the landscaping plans
that is proposed and this just focuses
on the western
boundary
sorry the western parcel
a significant number of trees will be
planted across the site and this
landscaping plan shows proposed trees in
gardens it's a little tricky to see at
this scale but there are a few in
gardens here
there's some more trees planted in
gardens here
and in addition there's some street
trees
proposed as well
in addition to the trees hedge and shrub
planting would also feature mainly to
the the front um
parts of
the plots to the dwellings
and then and the amenity green space
here would be laid to a mix of grass and
then other plantings shrub and flower
planting as well and the play space
that's required to be provided
by virtue of the outline consent would
be located in this part of the site here
in conclusion officers consider that the
91 dwellings proposed will be laid out
in a way which responds positively to
the spine road and adjacent residential
parcels and open space
the scale form and appearance of
buildings will be in keeping with the
context of the site and positive in
terms of the effect on visual amenity
the proposed soft landscaping including
tree planting would also contribute to
the overall standard of design that
would be achieved and the recommendation
chairman is one of approval subject to
the recommended conditions
before i ask
the
public speaker to speak gentlemen if you
want to remove your jacket because it is
hot in here you can do because i'm
really hot
if any of you want to remove your
jackets please be comfortable there is
one public speaker for this item and
it's mr alex clark thank you you will
have five minutes to speak and we'll let
you know when there is a minute left
thank you
good evening jeff and members of the
planning committee and thank you for the
opportunity uh to speak today uh my name
is alex clark and i'm the design and
technical director at bloor homes
tonight you're being asked to approve
the details of this fake latest phase at
wolseley park
you've recently approved the revised
outline permission at this site and
you'll no doubt have seen that large
parts of the wider site are under
construction including bloor's phase one
scheme
this reserve matters application relates
to two parcels of land within woolsey
park that are adjacent to the existing
bloor site
this latest phase will seamlessly adjoin
both the existing bloors site that
members approved in may 2020 and the
countryside scheme that you approved at
last month's planning committee
the wider woolsey park development
delivers the road network infrastructure
and large areas of open space that
surround all the parcels of this
development leaving just the details of
the housing areas to be considered
it is those details that are before you
tonight for the parcels that bloor homes
will deliver
your office officer's report provides a
thorough and detailed description of the
proposal and explains that is consistent
with the terms of both the outline
planning permission and your development
plan
given the detail in the report i intend
to simply highlight the key aspects of
the proposal
the proposal provides 91 homes identity
that your professional officer considers
acceptable
these 91 homes include 35 affordable
housing which equates to 32 new homes
the affordable housing has been evenly
distributed across both the eastern and
western parcels to the satisfaction of
your offices
the entire scheme includes a mix of one
two three and four bedroom homes which
has been discussed and agreed with your
officers as contributing towards the
housing needs of your district
the design of the scheme has evolved
through detailed and constructive pre
and post-submission discussions with
officers and advisors at essex place
services resulting in the unequivocal
support of the design officer at
paragraph 4.11 of the officers report
the proposed layout includes the
provision of a generous contribution and
continuation of the green lung and a
children's play area which exceeds the
requirements of the outline permission
the scheme also facilitates
good pedestrian connectivity with the
adjoining public space
a positive relationship is achieved with
both adjoining and proposed open space
areas to ensure that these areas are
well overlooked to reduce the risk of
anti-social behavior
essex police were consulted as part of
the application process and they did not
raise any concerns about the proposed
layout
members you have before you a scheme
that is without objection and that your
officers confirmed complies with both
the outline permission and your relevant
development plan policies
i can confirm that there are no barriers
that would prevent bloor homes from
delivering this site as soon as you
agree to the details of this reserve
matters application
i therefore respectfully request that
you agree with your office's
recommendation and approve this scheme
tonight and i thank you for your time
members
non-members attending does anyone want
to speak that's a shake of a heads
that's good thank you thank you for
responding
committee members we have world
councillors mr crips you've said no
um and councillor stanley have you
anything to say please it's got to be a
question not a statement
please just a reminder that this is not
just you this is to everyone on the
committee it is questions not statements
thank you very much
you've got five minutes yes
and
thank you thank you chairman um
looking on page 6.18
3.35 down to 3.37
and also 3.40
we know i noticed that some of the plots
are under size
in in
gardens
and
therefore
that we have a policy
of size of gardens i was asked the
question
why are we not delivering policy
procedures
and and making this a president
for other developments to be under size
this also includes size of rooms
where some of the rooms are undersized
maybe just by a few square meters but
that few square meters is is
considerable when you're trying to
plan for storage and what have you
also
i'd call into question
the road leading into both areas
there is no exit road should there be a
disaster happened on the entrance roads
at all
and therefore i would like to see
an exit road on both developments
chris
sorry council stannis you're asking is
there sorry an exit road
yeah so let's stick to that yeah we've
got to stick to the questions
this year i think it rode for these both
developments should there be any any
problems
for the future
um
it
and parking that was my other question
in some cases there is inadequate
parking
could you explain why
this is happening when we
are concerned with parking at the size
that we
policy recommends
and also that
with up and coming
industrial estates that might be or
commercial estate that might happen that
there isn't adequate parking we're not
talking about the other sites we're only
talking about this one so we cannot go
into other sites like commercial sites
etcetera you can only go into the blower
uh development on item six we can't go
on
what might be going around it sorry it
was mentioned by the yeah i know for
sure for questions we're actually the
questions need to be on this one please
so yeah so um it's to do with parking uh
our policy states there should be one
parking space per bedroom
single bedroom and two parking spaces
for two bedrooms
so why haven't those policies been
adhered to
if we continue down this road
we are setting presidents for the future
that's a statement can we just please
stick to questions for our officers
because they need to come back to you so
if you aren't
we just need you to do it so it's
concise for our officers thanks mr
stanley can the officers just tell that
tell me how they can justify
leading away from policy thank you thank
you crazy would you like to come back
yes please thank you
um so um yeah i've gone to those pages
that you're referred to first in
relation to the garden um
sizes to dwellings in in the report
there are 13 of the 91 dwellings
that wouldn't have
the 100 square metre
requirements that's in spd2 however your
supplementary planning document too
does state that the hundred square
meters um is advised unless um the
dwellings that proposed would be
adjacent to or near to um an area of
well-maintained well-managed public
green space so we've taken the view on
other
phases of this wider site
that
the
fact that a few of the dwellings would
not achieve 100 square meters is
acceptable with regard to that
supplementary planning
policy document guidance too
because of the amount of
wider strategic green space that those
dwellings would be within a stone's
throw off if you like and have the
ability to use
can i come back on that chairman please
would you like um
katie to answer all your questions i'm
sorry yeah yeah if you'd like those
please yeah i'll carry on um with regard
to the room sizes um
the requirement is that the dwellings
meet the minimum national technical
space standard
and um
correct me if i'm wrong but i'm looking
at the report there's a table on page
6.22
and then at 3.52 it says that all of the
proposed houses would at least meet the
minimum national space standard
requirement for the gross internal floor
area and built-in storage requirements
so i think what um the developer is
proposing is is compliant with that
requirement for the space standards to
be met so the dwellings would be
suitably sized
thank you um
with regard to if i take the the parking
next in inadequate parking in terms of
the bay sizes and that is referenced in
the report the number of base sizes
is in accordance with the
um sorry the number of bays that are
provided does accord with your your
adopted parking standard so two spaces
for a two bed or two bed plus dwelling
and one space for a one bed dwelling
and what the developer is also doing is
proposing i think 30 although i haven't
got the
paragraph in front of me
garages to properties so those garages
are
over and above
that
parking requirement so if you took all
those garages away the scheme would
still deliver policy compliance number
of parking bays
so the garages are in addition if you
like and it's the garage spaces that
don't quite meet that requirement to be
seven meters deep so they do meet the
width requirement of three meters but
they don't quite meet the depth
requirement of seven they're six so
they're still big
and they're still big enough to park a
car the reason why essex county council
and their adopted parking standard have
seven by three as the internal dimension
for a garage is to allow some
um domestic storage and that type of
thing that might happen in a garage as
well as parking
so
the garages are over and above
and they are the elements that don't
quite meet the
the bay size if you like all the
driveway parking spaces do meet your
preferred base size it's six point
two six about the garages
thank you
um
and then the the point about the um
the vehicle access points so there is
obviously the one vehicle access point
that i've pointed out to each parcel
essex county council highways have
looked at this application they're
satisfied that the arrangement for
vehicle access is acceptable
and so we don't think there would be any
basis for requiring the developer to
go back and reconsider the layout to
provide additional points of access um
for emergency services or or other um
or for other reasons
thank you katie yes you want to come up
with a supplementary question counselor
stanley
please if if i can
in relation to the parking i was
referencing the flats uh where
parking was supposed to be
and
and
they're not designated for any
particular
flat as numbered for parking sort of
thing they also the
um
i
i get your idea of the
of the
rooms
um
the gardens that you reference for
then
the gardens
the
allocated space that you would you're
recommending that um
they could use
that part of the area
for whatever activity they're doing and
does that mean barbecues and so
on um
with reference to the
council danny i'm sorry i missed that
bit can you repeat that about the bbq
sorry i missed it
officers said that the area
amenity space that the gardens don't
have
they've got the amenity space
outside of that area yeah but that's not
what to be honest this is not what we're
discussing we can't tell anyone what
they can put in their gardens or in
their garage no so that we
anyone puts in
their area
they will have uh storage spaces so
um
don't look at me as if i'm not stupid
no no so we can't discuss what people
may or may not have on their balconies
or maybe have in their areas we just
that's not what we're discussing tonight
we're actually discussing tonight
if we um what is all in the item six
and if we agree with the um
the reason that i'm saying this chairman
is that the
garden isn't adequately big enough for
them to use for whatever they need to
use it for yeah and if you've got a guy
that's a statement that's a statement
and i'm not going to carry on because
i've asked you to not to do statements
and i believe um
no i think sorry casey i think everyone
wants to come in as well so which of us
goes first okay um
sorry just to clarify i think i
understand your point councillor stanley
is that um
the
the private garden area each dwelling on
this site and the flats although the
flats will be provided with a communal
space which is in accordance with what's
allowed in your adopted in your
supplementary planning guidance but each
house will be provided with an area of
private amenity space okay and you know
perhaps you know people will have
barbecues or whatnot put their own play
equipment you know
do as they please in their private space
and that
will be used differently to how this
public green space is used surrounding
it but what your adopted policy guidance
allows for
is where dwellings are close to
a substantial area of well-maintained
space
people will will still use this but in a
different way to their private space but
it's still an amenity on their doorstep
and in that circumstance it allows for a
slight reduction if you like in their
area of private amenity space
but what each of these dwellings is
still provided with is a really
reasonable um we're not talking about
some of them having half of the you know
none of them go down to like half of the
100 square meters so we've looked at it
and on balance we're satisfied that each
of these homes the people living there
will be provided with ample private
amenity space and then have on their
doorstep access to this other kind of
really
good hopefully amenity with play space
you know communal play space for the
children etc okay thank you thank you
very much thank you councillors
right members
i've got two councillors indicating one
is i've got three more now one was
councillor can't store then council ohio
then councillor
let me write them down rather than i'll
forget you and who am i oh sorry i can't
see you down there so it's
councillor foster
this is wilson
councillor constable plays five minutes
as per
sure
they make the comments about plots 41
and 42 about the four spaces and it is
recommended that alternatives are
explored
has those alternatives been explored and
are our officers
happy with that addendum
so yes let me point out to you where
plot 41 is so plot plot 41 is here on
the eastern parcel
and you'll see that two of the visitor
spaces are proposed here in this
location so their driveway parking is
here they have access to a garage this
plot 41 and then these are visitor
spaces so i think the observation from
the essex the design team at the county
council is that visitor spaces should be
unallocated these will be unallocated
but because they're quite close to this
dwelling they might um conceivably be
perceived as
relating to this dwelling
we have looked at visitor parking
throughout um
in amendments to this um layout um and
the visitor parking this hasn't changed
but some of the other visitor parking
has such that overall we think that the
visitor parking is spaced out enough um
to mean it's usual usable for
you know the majority of the dwellings
should they say wish i mean clearly yes
these are close to plot 41 but but these
two properties here are close enough
that their visitors might park here i
mean equally you could say that you know
in relation to these two here you know
their visitors might pop up there and
part there um so that that that was the
point but on balance we are happy that
there is a spread of visitor parking
across both of these parcels and that it
is spread around you can just see
there's one space here there's one space
here
i could point them all out if you want
but um we're satisfied that the
arrangement is acceptable
and just on that are the visitor parking
places visibly
um marked out for visitors or is it just
going to be a different color or are
they going to put a label on the road
has that been decided at all yet
so there is a condition recommended
about the surfacing materials um to be
agreed um so
what we we could do if you so wanted is
to just um
give a bit more detail to that condition
to say maybe that we want the visitor
parking bays to be marked out as such in
it maybe a different surfacing material
or if it's the same surfacing material
provided with a sign or something
we we could certainly do that
thank you
um we're only allowed to ask questions
i'll take you
we are also allowed to
amend motions at
conditions oh yeah yeah yeah it's just
that i didn't want that i haven't
attended as a member for a year no i
just didn't want that any of us
including me we go rambling on and then
the officers don't actually know what
we've asked
that's and that does include myself
thank you i know i can ramble
we all like a ramble yeah i've gone
through through this obviously in quite
a lot of detail the concerns are around
the immediacy space again which i think
councilor stanley has raised but i'm i
don't want to go over the same ground
it's slightly different um
two how can the officers
remind us
how many two bedroom properties there
are because i noticed
all the two property properties meet the
50 square meter
standard
in the
this is a statement
in applications previously
i've noticed that
where a property
is only two bedrooms there has been
conditions attached which say it cannot
the bedrooms cannot be further
subdivided i know it says we have a
thing where it says if you can't
subdivide them because they'll be too
small but i have seen that certainly in
ones i've looked at quite closely very
recently we've had a condition where you
can't subdivide it and i know that
and if you notice if we have done a on
condition three we've said that then
they're not allowed to build extensions
on parking spaces for instance so i
think perhaps we should have the
condition there that they can't
subdivide
the second bedroom or to make more
bedrooms
i think on 6.22
there's i didn't see that because i was
looking in conditions
so there's three two bedrooms and six
twenty there's seventeen
so i just go to six point two two yeah i
did read six point two two but i can't
see it in the actual conditions we've
listed no there's no i'm not looking at
the number of bedrooms it's one two oh
yeah sorry you don't have one number of
bedrooms
yeah so when you look at um on six to
two house type number of bedrooms yeah
next column and there's one two then
calculate how many there are each test
type three so there's two
two bedrooms two
house types with two bedrooms is it two
no yeah two houses sorry yeah yeah so
that was a so i would
like
to add a condition saying that they
can't be those bedrooms cannot be
subdivided to create more bedrooms
if possible obviously members have got
to agree that yeah
also
there is talk of the two-bedroom
properties being able to use the amenity
space and i understand councillor
stanley's point that okay they're then
going to have a barbecue on them in your
meaning space i don't know if that's
possible or not can
can the office identify
where the
two-bedroom properties are and how close
they are to the amenity space
to see whether it's
i know it says that the officers
consider it reasonable but i'd like to
know on the plans so we can all see
clearly that they are
quite easily
accessible to the immediate space
that was it thank you councillor
katie
yeah sorry oh sorry
um
okay
so
what what i could do if you want me to
is so pat on page um 6.18 at paragraph
3.35
it identifies that all of the closed
dwellings save for 13 would be provided
with an enclosed rear garden at least
100 square meters in the case of
dwellings with three or more bedrooms or
at least 50. so and then it goes on in
the second um sentence to say the 13
dwellings that would fall short would be
and then it lists the plot numbers
so plots 5 and 6 plot 7 and 8 15. i
could point those out
if you want me to individually on the
layout because they're the plots that
are slightly i suppose what you might
say is under the the standard may i just
come back for clarity i'm talking about
the ones which technically meet the
standard because they're 50 square
meters
for two bedrooms okay the two batteries
i don't think they're included in the 13
because you say they meet
a standard and it is written in our
standard if you can't i understand that
but normally we
although we say it's not possible to
subdivide the rooms anymore
people
do okay i think sorry i'd like it as a
condition i understand right so
yeah okay we're fine
okay so on page then 6.22 and 6.23
that's where the big table is
um which talks which lists the different
house types so um the top line of that
table says the house type is called
savage and it's a two bedroom um you've
also got the stuart um which is a two
bedroom that's the first floor that's
the ff reference and then right at the
bottom of the table it says decker and
that's a two bed so what i can do if you
want is at least point to some of them
so this terrace of properties here i
know you can't see because um of the
scale but they are all decker properties
okay so they're the decker and what they
they're two bed and they would have
access if you like um just hop across
the road and then access onto this um
eastern bit here and then this leads
down to um the youth facilities that
will be provided um further to the south
what you can't see on this plan as well
but maybe you can on the location plan
here
can you see so there um
there is um other amenity green space
provided within this parcel adjacent as
well um and then there is the big um
play space that's provided on site here
okay just for a bit more context to that
site layout plan
so their deck of properties as are
these ones here okay so they're also two
bed properties
these are
referred to as the savage house type so
these two here so they're very opposite
um
these ones again are the savage house
type
as are these ones here
there's a couple of decker properties
here
and then on the western parcel if you
just bear with me a second
there are a couple of
savage house type properties here
okay so they would have access along
this pedestrian footwear here into this
area of the western space now you that
that might not appear very large on this
plan
but actually off off-screen that that
becomes a much wider area of open space
to the west okay thank you thanks
i think that's it
just the other questions is that okay
just about the condition that was all
yeah
we can put uh that'll go to the member
vote to do a condition i've written it
down okay okay so
i'll start it now so we won't forget it
um councillor foster
um i've got two questions about parking
um page 6.26 item 3.7
3.70 sorry
it talks about the need for three
disabled bays
parking bays for visitors
but then goes on to say that non excuse
me
excuse me none of the visitor bays are
actually in
visitor parking they're on
properties with disabled
wheelchair access
excuse me so my question is
why haven't we got any disabled parking
bays in the visitor parking spaces
that's one question
the second one is on page 6.26 as well
as 3.65
which talks about
a small number of
car parking spaces not being immediately
adjacent to dwellings or its enclosed
garden
but fairly close proximity so my
question is
how close is close proximity
and is the
non-on-site
parking
likely to drive towards on-street
parking
thank you council foster
so take the disabled bay point first so
um on this plan
i might zoom in slightly more
so
on this plan what you'll see is is the
reference to the visitor base being
specifically marked out
in relation to the dwellings that are
going to meet the wheelchair
accessibility
adapted standard
um so it makes sense that um some of the
so that
those properties are provided with a
disabled bay and they're the the parking
spaces that are shown
with a wheelchair symbol on them okay
but they're not the visitor spaces so
you're right that the parking standard
requires that three of the visitor bays
be provided and these visitor base so
there's one here for instance and
there's one here on this on the private
drive these visitor bays
are not specifically shown um to be the
dimensions of the
disabled bays but actually
there is sufficient space surrounding
them that would enable that that
additional space is so that doors can be
opened
and there's more access and more space
um to open the boots of cars as well
surrounding it so
there would be it's essentially although
it's not marked out as such these bays
would be
sufficiently usable
as disabled bays some of them
so so we're satisfied with that that
arrangement
your second point i think related to
where i'd noted in the report that some
of the
parking bays for dwellings wouldn't be
sort of immediately adjacent to their
house so you'll see for instance this
property here
they have their driveway parking
immediately adjacent to their side wall
and then they've got a garage space as
well and then this plot has a similar
arrangement
whereas some if i just point out what i
then
term
reasonably nearby um it's things like
like this so
here um this property here would have
driveway parking and a garage but this
property here would have their driveway
parking just here
so it's literally just at the end of
their garden type thing
so when we say sort of nearby that
that's where we mean it's a very short
walk and it's adjacent to part of their
cartilage
essentially
okay thank you can i just come back
briefly on the disabled base
if the spaces you've described are
suitable for
disabled
people to use why don't we just call
them disabled bays and make them the
appropriate size
could we make that as a condition
there's no reason why we could condition
it so we could condition for instance
that those two disabled those two
visitor parking bays that i pointed out
first here um in here perhaps could meet
those require
base eyes for a disabled bay
if you marked it out as a disabled bay
though what you would do is prohibit
other people from from specifically
using that bay
and whether that's what we want to do
i i'm not sure um but we could condition
it if members
felt the need
right i think i think that maybe the key
point is as long as they're capable of
meeting the size for a wheelchair user
to use them
then if a wheelchair user wants to use
them and they're free then they would
facilitate use by that person okay so
that they could come along and use those
comfortably
but if we marked it out specifically as
a disabled bay it would prohibit other
people at other times using that as a
visitor space
did you want to come in
okay thank you
council mrs wilson
can you put the mic around to you
because it's uh thank you is that better
can everyone here mrs wilson
yep sounds like thank you i only have a
couple of questions so i will be quick
um
the first question is regarding that the
green space particularly the play area
um i am unclear as to whether any
children's play equipment will be
provided in there and if so will it be
disability friendly
that is my first question my second
question is um
i'm sorry i don't have the reference
number but it's regarding the uh the
trees that are going to be included in
the street scenes
can
these be amended so that actually
they're street friendly
in that they don't drop fruit and
sapping or salts on the street thereby
causing problems
and my third question was just about
parking really for visitors um
is there a sufficient parking for the
number of residents
i think we've been through that one mrs
wilson i think we've had that question
and it's been answered on the parking
okay thank you that's it then thank you
and i do believe
in the report if i can find it does say
about the trees that will be planted
no it's um it's a
latte name which i can't find out what
it is didn't know what it was but um i
will actually ask
is it six point three one
six point three one yeah three point
nine two yeah
that's what that will tell you is if
you've got the papers it's 6.31
items
3.92 that's in your papers that you will
have read thank you
what was your other question so you've
done we've mentioned about the plant
trees we've already mentioned about the
parking what was yours
place spaces for uh the play area and
the green space would it be disabled
friendly yeah i was gonna ask that as
well yep so um the requirement for this
additional play area as part of the
outline planning consent
so
it's indicated to be provided in this
area here
and it's not the main play space that's
going to be provided on the wider site
as a whole so the main play space
let me just go back to location plan i
think it's actually if you drive to the
site you can see it um it's being
installed or has been installed it's in
this area here
um so that's the play space that has
much larger play equipment um
the play space um that's on this
in this area it is smaller in scale um
and the developer has provided us with
indicative details in sort of thumbnail
on the landscaping plan as to the type
of play equipment that will be provided
there
given the scale of the play space it's
not play equipment that
maybe would facilitate wheelchair users
but i don't think the the size of the
play space is such that that might be
achieved anyway i guess it depends on
the nature of the disability whether
some children will be able to access
this equipment but i understand your
concern
this is um indicative
of the type of equipment that will be
provided in this area and the detail of
that would be um
dealt with by condition
on the outline so the developer is
required to come with to us with the the
specifics of the play equipment they're
going to install there
if you wanted us perhaps to put an
informative on the consent for them to
consider um accessibility of that
equipment um for users we maybe could we
could do that
but it's maybe not um
you know it's maybe not the size of
equipment that's going to facilitate
wheelchair access anyway
in terms of street trees i think that is
covered in 3.92 well at least it's
covered in the sense that it gives you
some of the species of tree that are
proposed we have had our agricultural
officer look at the landscaping plans
and they're happy
with the species that to propose in the
positions that they're proposed and the
idea is that we want to ensure that
street trees are appropriate species for
where they're intended where they're
going to be planted because we want them
to be maintained in perpetuity you know
not have to be removed after a certain
amount of time so i think that's been
covered to ensure and i know that the um
the developer has in response to
comments from um
that were received in the consultation
changed the species of tree that are
proposed in this area here so that they
don't drop fruit yeah okay thank you
thank you
counselor mrs belton
thank you um councillor foster has asked
most of my questions they related to
parking also
but i just do have one point following
on regarding the disabled bays um the
ones you've pointed out are on the
outskirts of one of the parcels of land
now
that's a concern that it's very
difficult for a disabled person to visit
somebody living on certain parts of the
development so is there nowhere else
actual disabled bays or disabled
suitable bays could be put within the
development because it seems quite
a bit difficult for someone with a
wheelchair for example to visit this
estate unless they park on the street
and we know from previous experience on
other developments like this that on
street parking causes a number of issues
for residents for emergency vehicles for
waste refuge so have has this been fully
considered to ensure that we can't do
better in regards to disabled parking in
visitor parking
well
so um
the requirement in the parking standard
is that um well there's no requirement
um that on plot sort of driveway parking
to dwellings meets um the visitor bay
standard and these driveway spaces all
meet the council's preferred base size
which is quite generous
in terms of the visitor parking it is
this
three-bay requirement i think
bear with me i'm just going to go back
to that section of the report that
so it's on page 6.26 and 6.27 i think um
so
three bays would be provi would need to
be to the to your standard required to
be visitor
dimensions
um and i think at least those two would
meet would although they're not marked
out as such on this plan would have the
ability to have that extra width and
depth to meet that standard but wouldn't
be marked out as such so i think it does
in essence comply with the parking
standard that we have
but that doesn't
require visitor you know or most of the
bays to be disabled both sides okay
thank you understood
thank you uh council williamson
councillor fd
sorry
no thank you
chairman um
i've listened patiently this evening
and i've not yet heard any
any any legal reasons why this
application should be refused any legal
planning reasons
um on page 6.34
there are some informatives from essex
highways which to me seem very
reasonable
um
there's five there i believe if you'd
like to read the members
um
i would therefore like to propose that
we accept this
application
um with the conditions um the
informatives added as conditions and any
other conditions that members feel are
relative to this application
have you a secondary please
counselor
right members we've got motion on table
but i do believe and i'm going to allow
this if members agree that council
referee asked to speak right at the
beginning but he did actually say let
all members go uh before him because you
may have asked a question and he wanted
to i believe he wants to put a condition
in is that okay members that you'll
accept that
agreed
thank you daniel
thank you chairman
sorry
um
moving on from parking spaces to protect
our parking spaces i'd like to make
condition free to include the garages to
protect those from being developed as
bedrooms or other rooms so they will
actually need to go to planning
permission
to do that in the future
um yep so um condition three at the
present would um protect the driveways
um so it means that people can't if they
potentially could under permitted
development build outside extensions etc
and remove their driveway parking it
doesn't at the at the moment extend to
the garages because they're in addition
um to the two driveways
bases to most of the dwellings but if
you so wish we can incorporate um the
the garage of reference into that
condition right so we've already got
members we've already got one condition
already
um councillor hoy has put a condition in
we'd like a condition bedrooms cannot be
subdivided
too bad yep
oh sorry on just on the two bedrooms
wasn't it sorry
and council fd has asked that the
garages cannot be converted
unless it comes up again for planning
okay and there's an informative
information one is to consider 20 mile
an hour speed limit perhaps we could
change that from consider to
is where we're talking about castle 6.34
4.12.
so you want it um the consider 20 miles
an hour you want it
to have a 20 mile an hour speed limit on
yeah
i think um sorry i think on the
what i would advise is that we do put
the essex county council highways
informatives on any consent if that's a
member's decision um but i don't i don't
know that it would be appropriate for us
to say that they must achieve a 20 mile
an hour speed limit because that is
something that
the highway authority um have rules that
relate to um that we won't um
you know
you know we don't have all that
knowledge and understanding tonight to
know that that necessarily can be
achieved or is appropriate to be
achieved throughout
but i think certainly
essex county council the intention is
for them to adopt um a lot of this
anyway so it's going to have to meet a
lot of their standards anyway
about marking out the visiting
compartment
saying that a parking based visitor
that's material we can put that in as a
condition if you want yeah yeah please
right members
informatives will not be conditions but
they will be informative
we can't do it because it says it counts
these could be highlighted
well yeah because it'll be informative
and um if the s6 highways adopt the
roads they will um put their own words
in thank you chairman with that in mind
then i i would change my
my recommendation you know my um
so we've got to vote you've now reduced
uh no no
okay that's fine i'm prepared to accept
that as a part of mine okay so and you
still stand that you will uh put the
motion forward for approval and council
butcher your secretary right member
we've got members we've got um
recommendation on the table for approval
can i have a show of hands for approval
for this please
can you keep them up until sonia
actually
anybody
against please
abstain
so we've got ten four two abstentions
that is carriages agreed thank you
members
we'll go to item seven
let me get rid of all these papers
thank you
i can't hear you council williams
yeah
is it i don't know
is it okay you know it is now yeah
um item seven i'm i am actually became
inadvertently known to someone that has
something to do with the application so
i will not be voting on this i'll sit
and listen but we'll not vote on item
seven thank you
thank you very much
members
item seven
is for the 6365 spa road hockley and
it's like strengths it's going to speak
on this one
thank you um
this application is shown edge there in
the boulder square
um is on the
uh
just west of the junction with station
approach that you can see on the map
there and it's a
estate agent's office it's
just outside of the retail frontiers in
hockley uh town centre if we can jump to
plan two please just showing you the
existing building um you'll see it's
quite non-descript single story flat
roofed amongst bigger buildings and the
flatted schemes here and some
railings and fence details there
if we could go to the existing site plan
thank you
you'll see because the building is
fairly small it occupies only a small
footprint of the site
if we could go to four please
the proposal before you is for a part
three story part two-story building
to provide two
two-bedroomed and two one-bedroomed
flats four in total
and you'll see that in the report there
is
two off street parking spaces in this
area here
in the part of the ground floor of the
building
if we could jump to plan five please
you'll have to
scroll down to five of five
we see that the ground floor of the
building gives us a better view here
here we see the ground floor flat we see
the two car parking spaces being
provided in this arrangement here and
there was a previous scheme on this site
one of the reasons it was rejected was
the sort of lack of
active frontage as the urban designers
referred to it involving some planting
some sort of human scale if you saw in
the photographs as we zip down currently
it's paved and rather harsh so as well
as putting a bigger statement of a
building on there they're giving it a
more human um feel uh with some limited
planting that they can they can get in
um if we can go to the sixth plan the
second floor please
the second floor we see here would
provide the terrace which is
for the private use of one uh apartment
but this terrace is shared between the
ground floor and the uh one of the other
units you've got a shared amenity space
between two units here you've got the
um
private to here the private to the
ground floor one but there's another
unit upstairs
that shows that if we could go to the
side elevation plan seven please
the design follows a mansard type roof
what we mean by that is though it's two
story and it's got rooms in the roof
space and mansard is where these
roof slopes bend as it were instead of a
straight pitch
they they have this shape which actually
is precedented in in parts of hockley
the overall height is 9.5 meters
which is fairly characteristic of the
building of that sort
um if we could go to eight plan please
the front elevation which is the
principal one serving the the street
um sorry that's the
rear yeah sorry now stay with it
um
the existing building as i said is
rather understated and this
uh proposed building
has between two and three stories in
height it's significant in the town
centre that the buildings are of a
greater substance so what you you're
taking out effectively in townscape
stearns is a building that's rather
poor and putting in something of a
greater design given the town centre
location
in terms of parking full compliance with
the council's parking standards require
seven spaces but your standards say that
they may be relaxed where you're in a
town centre location as this site is
close to public transport we have a
train station nearby we have a regular
bus service and also we have services
available in the town centre and the
highway authority their standards that
you have adopted say that in those
circumstances when those factors come
together you can lower your parking
requirement
in terms of impact on neighbours
you'll see from the
side elevations that the
windows on this end
thank you
um they are quite close if we can go
actually find the site plan might be
better
um
of the existing proposed might be just
thank you that's the one the this edge
here is quite close to this corner of
the building here of claysworld court an
officer recommending in your report that
the upper floor windows along this
elevation be obscure glazed the windows
as they said i don't know if you can
show the second floor plan possibly six
you'll see that the windows that we're
concerned about they have uh borrowed
lights from other rooms so by obscure
glazing these windows you wouldn't be
limiting the
space inside solely being obscure
glazing so
the recommendation includes that
provision based on the close proximity
to the adjoining building
the recommendation chairman is approval
subject to the conditions you see on the
report
thank you
any visiting members wish to
nope nope
thank you
so
i'm gonna ask advice here
from
one of you
oh sorry yeah before i do that i've got
speaker before ask any advice
so we have
um mary power planning agent
oh hello
sorry i missed that
good evening chairman and members and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
tonight
the application before you has benefited
from some significant pre-application
advice given by officers
because there has been a history of a
number of schemes that have been refused
on this site so the applicant has taken
the time to take further advice from
officers to
reach a scheme that is acceptable as far
as they see it and we obviously see it
the building is reflective of the scale
of the adjacent apartment buildings and
its central towns town center location
where sustainable sites should be
optimized but only subject to
consideration of existing residential
amenity considerations
the development has been designed to
protect neighbouring residents both in
terms of the citing the development and
the location of bedrooms and open spaces
limiting overlooking
there is sufficient distance between the
new and existing claysworld court and
spark
apartments which will retain adequate
privacy and amenity for this urban
location
the existing trees will not be touched
and they are outside of the application
boundary in any event and therefore
their attention is controlled by others
outside the site
officers advise that some car parking
should be provided rather than car free
parking is in line with national
planning policy to encourage sustainable
alternatives to the private car
particularly in town centre locations in
good with good access to public
transport including trains buses and
other services and shops
considerate contractor principles
require the cleaning of the carriageway
during construction with all contractors
required to implement measures to
address dust and dirt on the footwear
and highway
should members require planning
condition for a construction management
plan to be provided the applicant fully
accepts this
the proposed condition five in any event
does require information to be submitted
and approved for the storage and
unloading of construction materials
clear of the highway
this will enable the council to consider
the effects of the construction of the
development in this location
objectives have also raised concerns
about secure bike storage it is a
requirement for bike storage to be
secure in order to encourage
alternatives and that is a fundamental
requirement to do that
whilst this is not a planning
consideration the proceeds of the sale
of this development will fund the
long-term care of the owner's daughter
who now needs 24 7 365 days a year care
which tragically arose from a severe
effect of unwittingly
eating a snack with peanut traces in it
the daughter is permanently disabled and
cannot care for herself
the development does not rely on this
however and we we consider the officers
do consider that the proposal is
acceptable uh in all regards
um into particularly scale density
overlooking and harm to residential
neighbours are they have a request that
members accept the officer's
recommendation and grant planning
permission for the
scheme thank you
i'll ask my question again if any
visiting members need to speak and as
you imagine it's exactly the same answer
um
we haven't got any other award members
but i'd like to ask advice
because
um councillors has given councillor
wilson
who called this in uh councillor has
called this in a statement to read on
his behalf and it is not five minutes
is this it going to be acceptable
we've allowed it before
it's not that long you said didn't you
five minutes it shouldn't be five
minutes yeah that's i just had to take
advice that's fine so i will now call uh
as the neither award counselors yourself
uh council wilson
thank you thank you this sorry council
ahoy
normally yeah yeah i've got you we'll
have you thank you
okay this submission
i'm reading out is from councillor eves
the application is contentious for its
location and scale
rdc parking standards and outside
immunity space are not met
however as the officer's report has
concluded in favor of the application i
see little point in proposing refusal as
the officer conclusion would give the
council difficulty at a possible appeal
putting that aside the issue that
concerns me is the position of the site
and its severely restricted operational
size from a point of view of public
safety and construction to the extent
that i believe there is a significant
risk to the public that is not covered
nearly enough by the conditions included
in the report
condition 5 page
7.1.12 of the officer report requires
delivery and loading to be carried out
within the cartilage of the building
site
when noting the amount of coverage of
the site by the proposal this condition
is impossible to comply with
i would ask the committee to discuss and
suggest ways that delivery loading and
storage of materials be processed that
is actually feasible and make it a
condition for granting permission
the pavement is heavily populated at
certain times of the day by students
walking to the greensward academy
there is no pavement on the other side
of the road to use as an alternative i
would ask the committee to consider and
propose enforce it enforced loading and
unloading times accordingly that reflect
the school times as an additional con
as an additional condition
it is worth noting that the spa road at
the point of the development is too
narrow for a bus to pass if the lorry is
stopped on the road to deliver
therefore i would additionally request
all members to consider a condition to
be included for a photographic record to
be made regarding the condition of the
public curve and pavement in the
vicinity of the site before the start of
the building
slash demolition work the expectation is
despite not being allowed for lorries to
mount the pavement to achieve delivery
that excuse me that this will happen
in the event of damage incurred as a
result of the process of construction
that it is specified as a condition for
all costs relating to repairs are to be
borne by the developer as a condition of
approval
previous similar
similar requests have been resisted by
officers but the position of this site
and the severity of risk to the public
warrant serious consideration to be
given to my concerns
i respectfully request that the
committee propose either deferment for
time to consider workable conditions or
impose the conditions accordingly thank
you
thank you very much
would you like to come back thank you
thank you chairman um
we have used the condition before on the
boardwood hall site which i have here
drafted um to limit con delivery hours
which were between eight to prohibit
delivery between eight in the morning
and nine thirty and fourteen thirty and
fifteen thirty monday to friday and
school term days
now
that
has a slight problem in being dated if
we possibly show the chief planners
letter at the bottom
more recently members will be aware with
the petrol
shortage et cetera the government issued
the chief planner for communities in
leveling up i don't know if you can show
me the show the letter
um but they did indicate that planning
authorities should be cautious
in
constraining the um supply chains the
wording is
up here
in this paragraph up here
and i'd be letting you down if i didn't
alert you to the fact that if we put the
condition on
there could be a risk if it was enforced
against that they'd say well we're not
following the spirit at least of
government advice of putting constraints
down to developers
to
uh make it difficult to service sites et
cetera what i have in mind is if a
delivery lorry they're loaded in certain
ways
so that if you like the first drop is on
the back as it were or something and the
last drop is at the bottom and they
stack stuff on top
if they got held up say by slow moving
vehicle or some other obstruction they'd
be late at the site here in hockley
this condition
could mean then if they want to follow
it they'd have to basically abort the
whole day's trips because they'd have to
they'd have to unload it all and repack
it instead what the drivers are highly
likely to do in those circumstances is
still attend the site in breach of your
condition which would mean then we'd
have enforceability issues
uh with this that would be exceptional
i'm sure you've heard from the speaker
earlier that they have the
construction management plans et cetera
so they've got every intention of making
this work
but
if members of i've got the draft
condition i'm happy to put it on if
that's what members decide to do but if
we come to enforce it there would be
some difficulties
the matters of photographic evidence of
the pavement and the developers being
costs for development they're usually
prosecutions under the highways act the
county highway authority when they're
doing big developments they usually
survey and monitor it in that way
and then when they feel that there's
been disruption kerbs breaking from
vehicles etc they use that evidence to
then recover the funds off the developer
i'm concerned that if we put that on a
condition
we're actually acting on behalf of the
highway authority i understand why
um and you know we're locally positioned
where we could act reasonably quickly
but
um i think the recovery of that is
primarily powers under the highways act
and i have to advise you that when
you're imposing conditions you should be
careful of imposing a condition that's
basically somebody else's responsibility
not putting a condition on
that is primarily the highways act
so i'm concerned about that i understand
the sentiment entirely
um but i have to give you that advice
before you before you make a decision
thank you very much
i've got two counsellors so far because
okay i'm not going to labor the
two parking spaces instead of the seven
the rules require
what i am worried about is the right
hand parking space there
um
i suspect the vehicles will be in their
nose first and they will be reversing
out
bottom right hand corner there's an
l-shaped
column holding up the upper floors
someone reversing out of that right-hand
bay is going to be focused for sure on
missing that
beam
column that's there
they won't be looking at what else is
behind them
on the pavement and on the site come to
that so i think
that
i would ask the officers do you think
that is a reasonable safe design
for reversing out there because i don't
know how they're going to get in
real first
coming off the main road so your
question is the question is is that a
safe exit
[Music]
no it's got to be a question not a
statement this is not become a question
when i explain it
i have serious doubts
about the constructability of this if
you give me the first floor plan please
you can see the storage space and
working space on this site is extremely
limited
i suspect there's an issue with getting
scaffolding on the right hand side
on the left hand side and amongst the
trees on the rear
that to the right hand side that white
next to the red dotted line is a is a
gateway there
and according to google earth there's a
footpath runs parallel with that wall
yeah can we have your question i'd have
no i don't care account scripts i've
asked ill members to do questions please
not statements
and that is what i'd like you to do for
our officers
well
i'm trying to explain no i would like a
question please account scripts i
actually asked councillor stanley okay i
know that
um
planning matters don't consider
construction
but we all have a duty of care
and health and safety i believe there's
a potential problem here
and when we move to conditions i will be
asking
for a
detailed construction method statement
to prove that they could work safely on
this site
so what is your question please i'll ask
you again please
i'll ask them have they i'll see
the officers
have you considered how this is going to
be constructed safely thank you
i like strengths
i haven't as the the member rightly
stated that matters raised primarily are
not um
planning concerns so
i mean members gift as to the conditions
that they uh see fit to put on
but just my earlier point that we do
have to be careful that we're not
uh
going through planning what are the
responsibilities of other
disciplines
can i come back please have you got a
supplementary question yes please
yeah i've got councillor foster i've got
you down
i've got
i've got fd constable stanley and
councillors foster right yes you've got
a supplementary
point
oh dude i miss you yeah councilman you
are down there counselor sorry
i just like the response to the officer
we all have a duty of care under health
and safety he's just asked answered that
he's answering me he said that planning
doesn't consider construction well i
think we have a duty now that is the
question that is what we are doing uh we
cannot
your the officer has actually answered
your question thank you councillor why
you were next
thank you i didn't miss you it's my
favorite subject which is parking
um
i'd like to remind the officers and
members that the actual
standard where it says
where it can be reduced says
a lower provision of vehicle parking may
be appropriate in urban areas including
town centre locations where there is
good access to alternative forms of
transport
and
existing car parking facilities
i think this is one of the first ones
i've seen where there are fewer
parking spaces than flats or properties
there are there are four properties two
parking spaces i've not i can't recall
seeing that previously i've seen
30 properties in 30 parking spaces um
therefore i don't think the parking
is acceptable on this site can i ask the
officers if they have it
considered existing car parking
facilities when they decided to
ignore our policy
chairman i'm not saying we ignored
our policy as the member just said it
says it may be reduced that's the the
thinking behind the rationale we have
taken into account the parking policy
the parking uh provision there's a
public car park near the library and the
medi center it's about what 10
perhaps maybe 15 with a slow walk
but it serves the town centre as a whole
so taking into account public car
parking there
bus services location of train stations
officers consider taking all that into
the round that your st your standard
says that you may reduce the
uh parking provision there was a
previous scheme on this for for a
more flats that had no car parking at
all
and as a result of discussions on the
failure of that and car parking wasn't a
reason
um officers led the developer to say
well look it would it would be better if
some form of car parking rather than
none at all was provided
but i take the point jim so could i just
come back i didn't quite hear how far
the walk was to the main car parker what
did you say
excuse me yeah it depends how um
able-bodied you are but it's the the
length of from this site to the um where
you see the
uh there's a restaurant an indian
restaurant and the medi center there's a
florist that you probably notice as a
landmark more down that side there
there's a there's a largest car park
public car park behind us
thank you chairman it's just a quick
question
um if
you just you've got a policy bit in
there which you had for the blood home
sites
for the um
timing of the
deliveries
where you you'd say not from 9 30 to
i think it was
that's why the board hall site
um
do we know what times the school
actually opened so we could amend that
if we go that far with this to amend
that to them times
as far as i know chairman um the
greenswood school which is the nearest
one i think they they're open at um
i think is it
i'm being told eight but
marcus might know
and they have a staggered pour out at
um three because a few years ago i think
they lost a pupil because there were so
many people on the pavement so they
rearranged their own exit time so that
some of the school came out about five
ten minutes before the rest of the
school yeah if we do so do get to that
point could we see that reflects the
score the one for billwood hall i'm not
saying um duplicate those hours if
that's meant but we've got a framework
here we'd have to do is put the times
and the members agree
okay
i'm being told
um 7 30 we could put in till say 9 30
and then what 14 30 till
15 30 in the afternoon cover that
i'd like to ask the officers whether we
can impose any conditions on the
contractors
for the loading and unloading of their
lorries that they put in
traffic conditions i.e lollipop men to
control the flow of traffic so that we
don't get a lorry parked in the road
blocking roads and traffic having to
work itself out i'll be able to put any
conditions on the contractors that they
have stop and go boards to control the
traffic so that it's
a
sensible
way of unloading lorries
chairman um the speaker
cited a construction management plan
which covers a whole multitude
of things and that could no doubt
include that
and you do see responsible builders
having a banksman
uh directing traffic there's a i believe
a matter of law that other than a
policeman you can't stop traffic
but most drivers have got common sense
to see if they're being waved through or
whatever if you're talking of traffic
lights
i think there's a permitting scheme
through the county highway authority
you can't just rock up and and set them
up etcetera i think there has to be and
again we're down we're delving into the
highway authority again
um
yeah i just wondered whether we could
have a condition of stop-and-go bulls
for the loading of unloading of lorries
though i know i know you need permits
but whether that could be applied for by
the contractor and granted or not i'd
prov i'd be happier if it was a
construction management plan which the
applicant said
they do have to do anyway it's not extra
work
and they could submit that as a
condition and then that would cover that
i'm i'm i'm not comfortable with
physical stopping of the highway by
planning condition without a highways
engineer beside me
sorry if that's still
confusing it doesn't quite answer the
question but as a planning authority
it's something surely we should be
looking at now even
the
developer to do is within the
construction management plan that they
submit to us
is actually
provide us with details of how they will
manage the site responsibly when it
comes to deliveries
so
we can't as as mr strengths has said we
can't
ask the developer to be present on site
with stop and go boards but we can
actually ask the developer to provide us
with details of how the deliveries will
be managed responsibly and that will
obviously incorporate those restrictions
on times to limit the disruption to the
traffic and i think that's as far as we
can actually go within the planning
remit
um two spaces are they allocated to
particular flats
first question second question
if they are
how would
one propose dealing with all the
friction that will cut if they're not
allocated how would one propose dealing
with all the friction that will come if
people have got cars
second part is
public parking up the road a few minutes
away you have to pay during the week and
saturday mornings
and
probably unreasonable twice people to
live there and do that
also on the matter of conditions
it doesn't feel quite right guessing
what they might be
and i would go along with the council
reeves proposal and suggest deferral
proposed deferral
so they can be sorted out
yes
so we have a motion on the table
members for deferral
can i please have a show of hands uh
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry i need to
know your reasons
construction management plan
so
we can impose a condition that requires
a construction management plan that
would then be have to be submitted for
discharge
and then we will then make sure that the
details in the construction management
plan are satisfactory for the
development to be carried out
with all due respect i don't think we
need to defer for that reason that can
all be covered by a condition
may i say i would like
we've gone around the table guessing at
things like start times and finish times
and i don't think it's reasonable for
the committee to be making a decision
based on such flaky information
so i stand by the deferral proposal i'd
like to see the construction management
plan and understand and then we can make
a proper decision based on facts
so
so we can actually add a condition to
the approval that restricts the delivery
times to what's been discussed this
evening
and then we can also ask for a
construction management plan
that talks about
the actual construction of the whole
site in its entirety
i've had that construction be managed
but we've still got this um motion on
the table for deferral i have got to and
we have a secondary
and we have had the reason for
can i have a show of hands in favor of
deferring please
know your hands members
against deferral
any abstentions please members
two extensions
what they asked if you it was for the
construction development plan that's
what you've deferring the application
yes that's what it is yeah yeah
so for deferral we've got four six
four against before
two abstentions
so it's so it's going to be deferred
thank you members
from you
i want your information
is other items that were
pertaining to this application have not
been discussed will they be brought up
at the next meeting of this if you've
got any questions regardless
let me cut your teeth back in sorry to
ask you
back in when it comes up
we will then discuss
only
what the deferral is for as you would
have done in other committees
when anything we can't ask any
supplementary question what if
or it's just for what we've deferred it
on as we've always done
so what so you can't ask questions on
other parts of the development
no no no so for clarity you can't add
the you can't make sure the abort
cultural officer's
recommendation for condition that won't
be put in now then
that's what exactly what i was gonna ask
but we can't because it wasn't in the
report it wasn't in the report
it's an addendum i think it's in the
attendance so does the addendum
condition going
we can't discuss it now we've made the
decision
we've gone for deferral it's been voted
on
yeah
as expected yeah
but it's confidently how we haven't
produced it
we have deferred it as
was asked we've
voted on it i've given you what it was
it's six four deferral
points
too abstained well point of order we
have asked for
no i can't do any more we've done that
we had put our names for
answering questions to the officers
okay
as you know council stanley it's a new
rule as soon as you have a motion on
this
table and it is seconded we have to go
to that
if it then got defeated
then we can jump back
this is not changed we have not changed
any of our procedures
and this will be in all the planning
training we get nothing has changed
since you and i have been on this
development committee
nothing's changed
so we're going to go on to item 8.
for the public have been taking the
opportunity to have a break may we have
a short recession for a couple of
minutes
when it comes to break yes please right
so it's
time five five past nine so ten past
members i'd like you back if you're not
back i will start
here i'm recommending that we go
straight to number nine and it is
because it is
excuse me members of the public can i
just explain
this is uh up for deferrals
which so we want i recommend we don't
have
um a discussion on it because it is for
deferral if i could have a secondar and
then
yeah we've got councillor stanley can i
have i recommend um everyone in favor of
deferring this because we can't discuss
it because it's up for deferral
well i'll get our officers to explain
why i've suggested this before we vote
we thought yeah of course before we like
thank you
i've just played
is
katie is going to do us a small report
regarding why we the deferral is on here
and then we're going to ask um
the outside mem person who if he wants
to he wants to speak and then we'll go
vote on deferral thank you katie
sorry
i don't understand the
vote to go straight to the vote we used
to be able to discuss motions
speak to emotion
yeah but what
i wanted to do says first the minute
yeah because to say because it's we
thought it was
going for deferral
and kate is going to explain the reason
why he's going for deferral we then we
will go from there okay thank you katie
thank you chairman sorry we're just
loading the um
plans
there we go um so this application is at
270 eastwood road um just south of
eastwood road it's the site outlined
here if i just go around the edge of the
site here
and it's this field to the rear
um the proposal was outlined planning
permission for 65 residential dwellings
at a care home
35 of the dwellings would be affordable
and 30 would be lifetime homes the
application is for
uh sorry the only reserve matters access
um so that is the only point that is to
be considered within the application uh
the main consideration points of the
application were the greenbelt
allocation
uh proposed access arrangements and the
acceptability including the number of
vehicles on the highway network flood
risks and drainage and trees there were
some other matters discussed in the
report but they were the main
considerations
um i'll take you through very briefly on
the main material considerations so
starting with the green belt we
considered the application to be
inappropriate development within the
green belt
due to it not complying with any of the
exceptions listed in paragraph 149 of
the mppf
um therefore it needs to come down to
very special circumstances as outlined
in the report we don't find any very
special circumstances in this case the
applicant raised
the fact that it would provide
a care home facility and older persons
housing as well as affordable housing
however we think that there are other
sites within the district that are
outside of the greenbelt that are able
to provide these including our own
allocated sites
in terms of the highway the accessing
principle is considered acceptable the
visibility display was
met the standards as outlined in the
manual streets however the access would
be located uh where 270 eastwood road is
here
so it would be between two residential
dwellings and no noise survey was
submitted with the application um also
sorry the residential dwellings down
south through close here would run aside
the access because no noise survey was
submitted we weren't able to properly
assess what the impact would be upon
these neighbours and we consider that
there would be a material change and
therefore this would need to be
considered by officers as well as
some specialists control consultees so
that has formed one of the
recommendations for refusal
uh in terms of flood risk the
application is located within flood
zones one two and three it's the stream
along the centre of the site
that has flood zones two and three other
side of it the if i just go on to the
indicative layout plan
the
dwellings would be located entirely in
flood zones one um and therefore it's at
the lowest risk of flooding and it would
pass this sequential test an exceptions
test on this basis
the there would be a bridge that would
go along the that would culvert the
stream so then the southern aspect of
the site would be able to
get out of the site that way the bridge
has been agreed by the ea in terms of
the structural and engineering
properties of it and they're happy that
even in the case of a flood those
residents within the southern aspect of
the site would be able to
access the
and leave the site still in that case
um however in terms of surface water
flooding there would be
an increase
of surface water runoff rates and
volumes
due to the increase of hard standing
there was a flood risk assessment and
drainage strategy submitted with the
application there was an initial holding
objection from the lead local flood
authority the applicant came back with
some further information to try and
address these points however the lead
local flood authority have maintained
their holding objection
then in terms of trees there are a
number of tpo trees including along the
central belt
and then other areas along the eastern
aspects southern aspect and western
aspect the agricultural officer is
content that in terms of the root
protection areas of those trees actually
within the site that the dwellings would
be able to be constructed outside of
those protection areas however there is
a tpo tree located adjacent to the
access which has not been included
within the tree protection plan and it
isn't clear whether or not the access
would be viable with maintaining that
tree and because of its importance along
eastwood road and its contribution to
visual amenity we've also included a
recommendation for refusal on the
addendum on that basis that the on the
loss of the tree
or potential loss of the tree sorry
because we're not sure whether it would
be able to be maintained
um and then the other reason for refusal
was that the absence of an air quality
assessment
the policy dm29 advises all major
developments need to include one and
there is an absence in this case and
therefore we're not able to
assess the impact of the development
upon air quality in the area
so
there were initially four reasons for
refusal a further
and further recommendation for refusal
on the addendum however we are
recommending that it's deferred as the
applicant has said that they are willing
to
provide the noise survey and air quality
survey for us and consultees to have a
look at to assess whether or not there
would be a detrimental impact that's not
to say that there wouldn't then be
reason they would still
form reasons for refusal or not it's
just that then we are able to actually
properly assess it in this case as at
the moment it's more to do with
insufficient information
thank you chairman
i'm going to ask
mr paul williams if he'd like to speak
you've got
you've got five minutes sir
and we'll give you um
a notification when there's one minute
to go
okay thank you
good evening chairman and uh members my
name's paul williams i live in 272
eastwood road
um
i'm here to avoid my objections to the
development as i have a major effect on
my property
but also there's a hundred plus
neighbors that have made objections i
will keep the time i'll stop the time
but we can't actually hear you that well
so um is that better that's fine thank
you all right i'll get closer thank you
right i'll start again yep okay good
evening chairman and uh members my name
is paul williams i live at 272 eastern
road
i'm here not only to voice my objections
to the development as it has a major
effect on my house
but the property
it also affects at least 100 plus
residents that have raised similar
objections
uh i believe there's a number of
residents in attendance tonight
unfortunately there's insufficient time
for me to actually carry out the
objections for everybody but i intend to
highlight the major ones
inappropriate in the green belt over
development in the green belt where
there are more appropriate areas
available pollution noise and air
quality during construction and
completion plus light pollution once
completed
loss of view overbearing impacts of
wildlife due to the loss of trees
including protected trees
loss of privacy overlooking house
security rising crime loss of property
valuation
impact on health and mental health
issues for the surrounding residents
putting more strain on the national
health
infrastructure
gps dentists schools etc cannot cope
presently
france's cotty lodge was reassigned due
to the decline in demand for over 50
sheltered accommodation
as there is is an excess
in supply of this type of accommodation
across the district according to the
council therefore why do we need it
current victorian drones does not cope
with heavy rain number of houses in
eastwood road have still and still have
suffered flooding from surface water
south view close also suffers the same
issues with a number of the residents
being recommended to register for flood
warning alerts
anger walter had two years
after two years of still trying to
resolve flooding issues for my property
272 eastwood road
the proposal of number of buildings and
hard standards would only increase the
flow of surface water to the brook
causing flood risking in the immediate
area and behind southwood close
traffic congestion eastwood road is a
very busy road with three speed cameras
within a mile of each other
with one only meters from the proposed
junction demonstrating that this is a
dangerous road the junction with
clarence road is hazardous at the best
of times and at this junction there has
been a number of accidents including the
attendance of the air ambulance
and in another junction only meters away
would only increase these hazards to
vehicles pedestrians
not to mention one under construction
the latest highway traffic survey was
carried out between 10 o'clock and 10 45
which is a very quiet time on that road
i personally
have counted one vehicle per second
in eastwood road at rush hour
eastwood road is also frequently used
for emergency vehicles
a number of requests for dropped kerbs
due to the lack of parking facilities
along eastwood road have been rejected
as introducing unnecessary danger to
highway safety they could not comply
with policy dm1 and paragraph 32 of the
nppf
how then can a proposed development
road junction to be accepted a drop
curve would only add
one to two vehicles crossing eastwood
road each day
development with this development would
see at least 250 to 300 vehicles
using the junction daily when you take
into account the number of houses houses
residents care home residents and their
support staff there will be vehicle
movements because of
care home visitors medical deliveries
taxis online purchases shop deliveries
general visitors
refuse collections commercial food
laundry
a 24-hour visit to am visits with
ambulances 24-hour staff movement
the suggested bus stop relocation would
cause more hazards and possibly the
reroute of number 20.
impact on access access to the current
eastwood road properties and pedestrians
all of which gives noise air and light
pollution
so the new and current residents alike
giving more health mental problems to
the overstretched national health
service
major impacts of heavy development
vehicles
on 272 considerable impact to 268
eastwood road and on 1 to 19 eastwood
south view close
272 road has deeds going back tonight
1854 therefore i believe the foundations
and structure would be affected
the use of updated uh outdated surveys
to support this development
a poor design insufficient true to scale
layout thank you
well done thank you thank you
[Applause]
right we need to speak to the deferral
so i will put a motion on the table to
for deferral
and can i have a second and then we'll
speak to councillor foster
councillor
i think we've got four
reasons for deferment
katie any other reasons members can
would like to add for the deferment so
we can discuss them when this comes back
okay
oh sorry
the current five reasons for refusal
including the one on the addendum
the one on the addendum will go
forward to the next meeting when the
deferral is heard
yes
oh there we go
it will depend on the outcome of the
surveys whether they will be maintained
as reasons for refusal
and i just wanted to be clear that is
the second third fourth and fifth
reasons for refusal that i would expect
further information on the first one
they've they did submit further
information on and that was included on
the addendum and i didn't think that
that
outweighed the harm of the green belt
still so it's to do with the suds
uh noise survey air quality so survey
and the trees
uh tree on eastwood road that
i'm recommending deferral on
and they sorry and if they are not
overcome they would be maintained as
reasons for refusal
um with the green belt as well and they
may be updated um depending on the
information
yeah at the moment they're mostly around
insufficient information um so that it
may be that we speak to the information
provided as reasons for refusal or um if
removed as reasons for efficiency
for deferral as as the committee
requires i still don't understand why
we're voting for a deferral when first
and foremost this is being built or it's
being recommended to be built in green
belt that won't change and there are no
special circumstances so i would just
like that to go on the minutes right
thank you councillor williams it did go
in for refusal
uh this application then the applicants
saw and think
think
they can
go with
address some of the reasons
so the officers have decided that's what
they'll get their reports back we have
not will not make a decision
until we've had that so that's why we
are the off we're going with the
officers recommendation for deferral
i'll bow to that but i would like to
point out that
i'm still not happy about being in green
bell thank you no no councillor williams
it
if you read it it does say and county uh
casey has already said
it's still uh there is still the problem
with the green belt that is that's the
very first thing she said right way
through this okay cancer standing and
then we're i'm going to the votes
also be for the suds that's what that's
what katie has said if you read your
report yeah before
things so she has already said that all
right yes i know yeah and she's in the
report
and who's oh hello sorry okay
um i don't know sorry that's okay just
just to be clear and we've got the
reasons for deferral given the the
speech that we've heard from the members
of the public and the subsequent support
from the residents can we ensure we're
able to discuss those points raised at
the next meeting because i wouldn't want
that to be silenced
yes of course that was that thank you
councillor belton that is a given when
it comes when it whatever we we've got
to make sure what we defer it on the
points and that's the only things we can
discuss when it comes back we can't
think when we go up home tonight oh we
should have asked this we'll start it's
the items so can we now do a vote
go can we just put um taking from what
the gentleman said over development
like you can on deferment put it on this
we can discuss it so defendant light
pollution loss of trees and care home
assessment they can be on the deferment
as well so we can discuss them so
they're not left out
sorry members we can't sorry sorry
members we can't take questions from the
floor
sorry we can't take we can't take we
this is a committee
it's that is highways it's a highways
matter and we have got to go with what
we're talking about now we're going for
deferral so can i have a vote a show of
hands for deferral please
for deferral
members can you
lower your hands
for against
deferral
against deferral
anyone abstaining please
three against deferments so members that
is and none obviously
abstained so members that item nine will
be deferred and it will be coming back
to committee with the officers
report thank you
members item we'll go back to items
this meeting has now lasted roughly two
hours so we would
i don't think we now need a
ten minute break because we just had one
though firstly though i'd like to move a
motion without notice according to
committee procedure rule nine
in brackets end to extend this meeting
be on two and a half hours
for as long as practical
in order to complete the business can i
have a secondary
councillor belton voting
can those in favor please raise their
hands this is for an extension to get
item eight completed
members against the extension
any abstentions
that's carried members there's eight for
the extension two against one abstention
thank you right we'll go on to item
eight
find it
this is the land between hillside road
and new england wood estate rise
eastward
change of the use of paddock land to
proposed riding stables
is it
mike strength thank you mike can you
please carry out on thank you thank you
chairman um this application is to a
site
uh of sort of currently open grassland
area here on the side of eastwood rise
um the site of principal part of the
development is in this shape here with
an access
uh down
to the corner
just sonia's in my line of sight with
the pen no thank you that's all right so
the
access comes down to here so it's an
irregular shaped site but broadly
rectangular hopefully that's clear
to members
the proposal is the relocation of a
current riding school which is down here
almost opposite the site
to this land uh the other side of the
road
and it involves provision of some
stables
the menage area an exercise minaj and
a
building for holding parties in that's
also got staff accommodation and a bin
store we'll see those in a moment but
the principal use as well as the
storage and care of the animals is the
recreational activity
um at the existing site there are five
horses ten ponies and two miniature
ponies uh 17 in total and a number of
other animals such as lambs sheep pigs
rabbits guinea pigs that provide petting
and a sort of an animal experience
mostly for children
um if we could see three plan just go
through the elevations please of the
buildings this is the largest building
this is the stable building officers
have reduced it from 20 to 15 following
concerns of the size of the building
though it's a traditional design all
three buildings have got all four sorry
buildings have got
a brick plinth to the lower part wooden
cladding to the sides and green coloured
metal sheeting
onto the roofing that's pretty standard
that you see
with stable provisions throughout the
district
if we could jump to plan four please
this is the the so-called party building
it's a an activity room primarily where
the the children and party goers would
eat so therefore it needs a kitchen
toilet facilities and the applicant has
revised the design to include some staff
accommodation features there just sort
of restrooms areas for the staff to
break out
if we could go to
uh plan five please which is the barn
members will be familiar that often
barns uh are located away from the
animals for sort of fire risks basically
if you've got combustible stuff in there
like straws and haze it's not good
practice to have them located as part of
one building they're always separate
this one interestingly has
solar panels
to the roof
if we could see plan
six this is just a bin store for the
refusing closures the applicants rather
than have things out in the open they're
proposing to put it in a small building
and if we could rest on the site layout
please
um members will have seen from the
report just to locate if we can shrink
asset great the stable building here the
party building here the bin store in
this part
members will see that there's some car
parking proposed and the service access
road into offices have also got the
applicants to reduce the car parking but
that is still more than what they need
to comply with your
parking standards
the
issues primarily
are that
the building though is located in the
green belt
your policy and government policy allows
recreational uses in the green belt and
bear in mind also it's just a transfer
of the use that's the other side of the
road will be in
better designed updated buildings
in terms of highway impacts again the
existing presence of the existing
use
more or less transfers the activity
across the road
so officers conclude that there would
only be a negligible impact difficult to
determine over and above the harm so far
with the the existing use
in amenity terms there are a number of
residents backing onto the site
the building has a visual impact but
bearing in mind that policies have uh
allowed in in the green belt the
provision of recreational uses like this
stables football pitches and the like
and necessary buildings that accompanied
that
you'll see that the report concludes uh
with the views expressed by residents
that we can
uh limit the hours of the parties to no
later than 7 pm in the evening to
safeguard
that they also sound insulate the party
building
and bringing floodlights within control
now that takes me to the addendum
members will see that
as drafted in the report before you the
condition
prohibits all lighting and that wasn't
intended if you take the condition
strictly it would mean they couldn't
have a light on in the stable when
they're mucking out things like this
what the intention was was that if the
applicants at a later date they're not
proposing it now but wish to flood like
the menage or other parts of the site
then that can have a certain amount of
light pollution and distraction
so officers say in a condition
that is necessary that brings that flood
lighting within control
so the recommendation is approval but
subject to the revised condition um on
14
as set out in the addendum thank you
chairman thank you very much
we have two uh public speakers for this
item we have stephen avery the planning
agent please
again mr over you will have five minutes
and i'll let you know when you've done
before thank you
thank you chairman and um good evening
councillors my name is steve avery and
i'm speaking in support of the
application and on behalf of the
applicant miss nikki burch who is also
in attendance this evening
i do not intend to rehearse all the
relevant policies and planning
considerations these are clearly set out
in your office's report
but i thought it would be helpful if i
just highlighted a few matters
firstly prior to the submission of this
application the applicant sought and
received favorable pre-application
advice from the council which recognized
the positive attributes of the proposed
development and confirmed that it would
not be considered as inappropriate
development in the green belt
on this basis the applicant commissioned
detailed plans and submitted a full
application which was registered by your
council in april of last year
so the intervening 13 months reflect the
considerable discussion and negotiation
that has taken place between your
planning officers and the applicant to
arrive at an acceptable scheme for the
site
this has included amendments the
original submitted plan some of which
you've heard about to reduce the overall
scale of the proposed development
commissioning specialist reports on
ecology trees and drainage and three
rounds of consultation
as a result of these changes the
proposed buildings now sit much more
comfortably on the site
their simple low-key design and use of
traditional materials combined to
provide the buildings with a very rural
appearance and character and one that is
in keeping with the area
additional landscaping will help to
further soften the impact of the
proposed development and you've heard
already that the car parking standards
are met and exceeded
you will note from section four of your
officer's report that there are no
objections from any of the statutory
consultees and this includes the county
council as both the local lead flood
authority and highway authority
natural england anglian water and the
environment agency
a significant amount of work has been
undertaken to agree with surface water
and foul drainage arrangements and these
are detailed on pages 821 and 823 of
your report
many people have written to the council
in support of the scheme but we
acknowledge that concerns have been
raised by some local residents we
believe the additional supporting
information and revised players have
adequately addressed these concerns
it is important to remember
that this proposal seeks to relocate an
established and well-regarded local
business from one side of the road to
the other
the proposed facilities will undoubtedly
be an improvement on the existing
buildings some of which are in a very
poor state of repair but that is not to
say that the resultant development will
lead to any significant increase in the
use existing use over and above that
already taking place at this end of
eastwood rise
and you will know also from your report
that the applicant has no secure tenure
over the existing ramblers site
and in all likelihood we'll have to
vacate the site very soon this is
because the council has accepted that
the existing rambler site can be
developed for housing subject to
satisfactory drainage arrangements and
this is itself now the subject of a
current application
time is of the essence other concerns
raised by local residents can be
controlled by suitable planning
conditions such as protecting existing
trees controlling flood lighting
limiting hours of view sound proofing of
buildings and agreeing a travel plan
these and more have all been agreed with
the applicant
in summary this is a well-designed
scheme agreed with your officers and one
that is appropriate in the green belt
the proposed planning conditions will
ensure the council retains effective
control over the use of the site and
that the development will be carried out
to a high environmental standard i would
like to conclude chairman by just
reading a very short statement on behalf
of the applicant nikki burch in her own
words
as the co-founder of the ramblers riding
club i have asked mr airy to speak on my
behalf as i feel that my emotions may
get the better of me
myself and my staff have such passion in
what we do from our lessons to our
therapy sessions
we have a great reputation in our local
and surrounding area and we witness
daily the incredible impact our animals
have on children and adults but most
importantly the ones that suffer with
mental health and sin issues
the ramblers has become a haven for
people and many if not all our
volunteers suffer from some form of
mental health
we are not wanting the new site to
generate more business we just want to
offer facilities of the highest standard
and if our current site gets planning
for houses we need a permanent facility
for our own to secure the future of our
center
we have so much to offer the community
and our work has been recognized and
offered grants of support from
organizations such as the rockford
rotary club but we are unable to accept
these any of these until our planning is
approved and we have a permanent home
myself and my family have dedicated our
whole life to the ramblers and it's our
animals and we cannot begin to imagine
life without it as our animals are our
therapy too
i hope you can support your office of
recommendation counsellors and thank you
for your time thank you very much
the second speaker we have is mr brian
miller who is an objector thank you mr
mayor exactly the same you have five
minutes and i'll give you
oh when it's four minutes i'll give you
i'll tell you thank you
mike is on is the mic near enough can
you hear me yes
yes we can good evening madam chairman
councillors my name is brian miller and
i've lived in eastwood rise
for some 33 years
i feel i need to give a brief background
because
this part of rochford is the forgotten
part of rochford
most people don't even aren't even aware
that we are in rochford
until 1996 the area north of gravel road
was designated an area of special
restraint designed to provide a buffer
zone between the urban area of eastwood
and the greenbelt area in rochford
no new building was permitted at all
eastwood rise at that time was an unmade
private street
under pressure from developers rocha
council created a design brief
that specified the type and number of
properties that we built in the area
each new property had to contribute to a
road building fund which paid for
eastwood rise and rayleigh avenue
to be made up
but these roads remain private streets
and are defined as being for the benefit
of the frontages i'll come back to that
in a moment
the site under consideration has only
had access to eastwood rise for a year
or two
and the gate was put in i believe
without any sort of planning approval
so this must create a question about
their rights to use eastwood rise for
this business
has any consideration been given to the
act to the access for the construction
vehicles
especially at the actual point of their
gate it's a very narrow unmade road
the stables location is confirmed as
green belt
which in my opinion needs to be
preserved
the whole development does not fall
under any of the exceptions that would
allow the construction of new buildings
quote
one of the exceptions is the provision
of appropriate facilities for outdoor
sport outdoor recreation
the party room and even larger barn are
far larger than is appropriate for the
enjoyment of up to 15 horses
i thank the committee for their detailed
analysis of current policies on planning
consensual equestrian facilities because
i wasn't aware of them
development contravenes these policies
in several ways
it does significantly undermine the
objectives or character of the green
belt
and quote it has a great impact on the
openness of the green belt
applications for equestrian development
with essential ancillary facilities will
be supported providing that the proposal
is for a small scale development
brackets fewer than 10 stables these are
your words not mine
this development would not represent a
small-scale equestrian development under
this criteria as the proposal is for 15
stables
i.e 50 more
than the maximum 10.
to further quote the land available to
support the horses on the site equates
to 4.04 hectares this calculates the
widest site along with the paddock of
the application site
technically a development of 15 stables
will require a site area of six hectares
to comply with this criteria
and in spite of these
facts that are against the proposals
laid down on equestrian development in
greenbelt areas the report still manages
to support the
application eastwood rise would not be
able to accommodate the additional
traffic generated by the business
the single track roadway between
hillside road and nor road was designed
as a speed restriction appropriate for
use by the cars owned by the residents
in the eastern section of eastwood right
hillside road sorry and the bottom of
eastwood rise
these traffic movements will be
throughout the day
and not up to 40 cars concentrated at
the start and the end of the parties to
be held
there is no bridal way access to the
site which means that all horses leaving
the site would also add to the
obstruction of eastwood rise
unless the public footpath into cherry
orchard is used which the council have
said must not happen
the argument that essex highways report
is there'll be no increase in traffic is
ridiculous
the existing stables are parking
probably for 10 vehicles
must be noted
that 49 of the supporters of the first
application only three are in the
immediate area over 30 of the supporters
travel past six other equestrian centers
from their home address to the site
under consideration
they have organized two events already
when over 100 cars were parked on the
paddock grass
they have another event planned for the
5th of june and are advertising for
craft stalls
how can these be considered equestrian
activities
what remedies will be open to the
council if the operators exceeded the
permitting opening hours would the
council shut down the whole operation as
they would do a licensed premises
i doubt it
can we be assured that the location will
never be granted an alcohol license can
there also be a permanent restriction on
any further development on this site by
putting the stables at the bottom of the
site to me
okay fine thank you sorry
thank you very much
we have one uh
visiting members anyone want to speak
councillor night
no no no it's only councillors i'm
afraid
no visiting members we have one ward
member councillor lamborghin
i'm sorry i can't see him councillor
you
um it's about the the runoff the
drainage
there is the um
fishing club just below this uh site
and i'm very concerned that the um
drainage
although on the site will be contained
but is will there be any over there
will be any over spill into the
into the fishing area
in particular because that's been there
many many years and
we don't want it to be polluted
details to be submitted for the
condition nine details to be submitted
for the service water drainage scheme
so they would drill down into the
details of the minutiae i think the way
the site works and the location works is
that surface water does go to the
ditches i think what would be important
is that any captured water would be
filtered
and that usually what happens when you
get car parking areas the
toxins and the rubbers and the
pollutants that come from parked cars
they normally run through an interceptor
of some sort to clean the water up
before discharge so that's what i would
expect to see on those drainage details
when they're submitted
you got something yeah yeah i mean can
we make a condition that that actually
happens
the condition required if you're saying
the provision of interceptors we can we
can specifically put that in yes
yep that can be done
sorry thank you chairman
um
what i see dm15
um it seems like we're not compliant on
one although it is close to the previous
site so it might you might get away with
that
this is a point raised by the speaker
which is dm 15.2
the maximum number of stables per
hectare is related to the amount of open
space the requirement with no more than
one stable for each 0.4 hectares of salt
area i know this has been put up in
previous applications i know mike
strength has commented on that can he
just confirm that we this meets that
requirement or not because i was
understanding from the speaker that we
don't
this application doesn't meet that
requirement
it doesn't meet the requirement i think
the report makes that clear yeah but
what
you'll recall that the government
is guarding against prescriptive
measurement policies okay
and what the
nature of the beasts on site is
is that to standardize that every horse
requires uh an acre or point four of a
hectare
is wrong some of these animals have a
condition probably laminitis which means
that they don't need grazing it's
actually harmful to them too much grass
causes the sugars to rotate a bone in
the hoof and they can't walk
so
following the care regime and following
the horse sizes the british horse
society standard is actually far more
elaborate than it was when dm 15 was
drafted
that it says you have
bigger areas and smaller areas depending
on the horse so we've it's been averaged
out of 0.4 so taking that in the round
offices are comfortable that the size of
land available
for the activity that's being proposed
and the animals that it concerns because
some of these are miniatures etcetera
for the nature of it that there is
sufficient gravity there wouldn't be a
welfare issue
and you can you can look at the existing
facility and how the animals are cared
for um as a gauge for that so officers
are content that there's enough room in
this case on merit
i'll come back i do seem to remember us
application
wakering everywhere that this was raised
how couldn't
they maybe then was going there how can
are we able to restrict the animals to a
size
then if the or or or a condition i'm
aware of that condition
um if we're not able to restrict it to a
condition of the horses or the size of
the horses then
then that argument fails doesn't it the
policy
we've effectively allowed i think a
horse is on there despite the policy i
don't know how that works yeah i i see
the point um i think the nature of this
builds business business we've said it's
on merit is that we're not dealing with
athletic horses that are competitors
jumpers or dressage or whatever 16 19
hands
the nature of the horses here is that
some of them are small and
um let's call it cuddly or whatever the
whole idea is the interaction
so those kind of horses don't require so
much space
and and that's the issue so i imagine if
some of the horses on site died
and they were replaced i'm expecting
that they were replaced with similar
animals that
satisfy
the criteria of the the parties the
animal petting and things like that
um for my combat i would also expect
that but we know that my expectations
aren't always met
um at the moment i see it fails on the
three points i've said so i'll just
leave that there for the moment thank
you counselor stanley
thank you chairman uh just a few
questions
one is that can we make conditions of
the
how many horses that are allowed to use
the stables
also that the stables will not be used
for any residential purposes
and
to have a
water quality refinement put in
from those stables
as
there will be considerable amount of
washing down of horse
and washing out the stables
council stanley i think that was
yeah so we don't need to go through that
because councillor manbon's asked for
that
no he's already asked that to be in a
condition so i didn't realize we'd said
that as a condition yeah please sir so
we don't need that as another we don't
need a duplicate a condition okay
as a condition sorry
um
sorry um
yeah they took me on my track now
um
well the other oh yes the other thing
sorry um do give me a bit of time the
other thing was
for vehicle movements up and down
eastwood rise
as you very well know the properties
there
are battling with essex county council
on the adoption of the road so is there
any way that we can
um
not
put well left to put a condition on
those using the stables in other words
in the wear and tear of that road before
the
as it is a private road it's like is
this a question it's a question can
uh so it'd be down unfortunately
um we can't rest essex county council
will have to do if it's a road or
whatever we won't be able to put a
condition on it if i'm right
or am i wrong
chairman while i'm in i can answer the
the other ones briefly but i'd be
content if members felt a condition on
the number of horses
was required that that could be
enforceable
not used for residential you wouldn't
need a condition on that unless you're
anticipating far more elaborate
government pd rights
at the moment to convert to residential
requires planning permission so you'd be
you'd be putting a condition on
preventing conversion for something that
needs planning permission anyway which
under the current legislation the
government wouldn't uh encourage you to
do so i would say you don't need again
to guard against conversion
um but i could accept uh
we could draft a uh condition on the
numbers of horses
would you like to come back yes
the condition on residential is not
is that
in some cases
they do sleep over
for
for
uh
reasons i don't know but in some cases
that's the reason why i asked about
residential gym
yeah so but you've had the explanation
and like
but he's to come back to you
i would just say
it's well known that sometimes animals
when they're sick they need 24-hour care
that's not residential that's that's a
groom or somebody saying overnight or in
shifts
um to yeah or even sometimes with horses
give birth you know that the labor
period they need somebody on hand so
it's not unknown for there to be
somebody if you like working through the
night
looking after the animals like farmers
do win lambing and stuff like that but
that wouldn't be a residential use
that wouldn't be somebody's home sorry
jim sorry like it so you were saying
it's okay for animal welfare that
someone like a bet groom blah blah blah
for it to qualify as residential there'd
have to be a material change in the use
of the premises it would have to become
somebody's home but if somebody was was
attending a vet or or some difficulty
where they needed to be
staying at the site until the mata
resolved which is usually animal care
then there wouldn't be a a bridge of
planning control there no
but perhaps if they said they have to be
there say 11 months
for animal care then enforcement
officers would probably start to get
interested if it was an excuse
okay members okay thank you
oh we've got two more councillor
constable council belter whichever is
first oh thank you and just just a quick
one i mean based on everything i've read
and heard in the report i see no reason
to refuse the application and in fact i
think it's
it sounds like a fantastic business
that's bringing people into the area
based on the people that have supported
it but i do have a couple of questions
following on from the objections and the
speaker that we heard second
in regards to the question raised about
licensing on a site like this is that
something that could be is it that could
be considered in the future i'm not sure
on the licensing rules around green belt
and change of use so just to ask that
question if i'm if this is the right
forum for that
secondly a question was raised within
the objections about mirrors on the lane
because of the
the awkward access
would that be something that we could
put as a condition or does that come
down to essex highways i know it's not
adopted at the moment by the sounds of
it and but just for safe access for
people in and out
and finally regarding the point of and
again this this is hearsay essentially
100 cars parked on the grassed area
during an event is there anything that
we would need to consider to limit that
to
make sure that the area is not being
overused or used in the wrong way thank
you chairman um
dealing with the mirrors you could only
ask an applicant to provide under a
planning permission mirrors on their own
site so if the concern was at the
entrance or the exit
to
the proposed site we're dealing with now
you could ask them to put mirrors on if
the concern was to put mirrors down the
street then that's off the site they
have no control over that they could
even if people wanted to they couldn't
put it on effectively their land
and then you'd be into to the highway
authority
um
with licensing uh it's important to
distinguish planning licensing
from a if you like a pub an alcohol
sense
and parties that way that deals with
social behavior yeah it doesn't deal
with green belt it doesn't deal with the
matters that concern this this committee
so
you could grant planning permission for
say a football club clubhouse
and they decide they want a licensed bar
that doesn't interfere with your
planning permission yeah
now with the hundred cars and the
activity you'll see that there's a
condition in the
recommendations if i find it
isn't it
um i'm looking for the one that talks
about jim carnas as well hasn't there
been no parties after seven o'clock
which was in the presentation
there's a condition somewhere i have
noted if i can't find it at the moment
but there's
uh one of the conditions restricts the
use
there are condition number five
um that
looks at jim carnas but we could expand
that
to
uh and i think there's a there's another
condition here somewhere that limits it
to the use anyway
13. so so if you look at a marriage
between condition 5 and 13
13 limits it solely to the use that is
proposed before you
condition
condition 5 looks to safeguard against
horse related events gymkhana's fares
that sort of thing now if other
boot fairs are saying nothing to do with
equine are what we're being told is
going on
um you could expand condition five to
include those things on the back of
condition 13 which limits it to the use
proposed anyway if approved thank you
constable
page 8.16
under 3.33 the highways and public right
of way it talks about the entrance into
the site as being an unmade road there
isn't anything on this
planning application that
says that the users of it um will
maintain it and i'm concerned that with
the traffic going up and down
there isn't anything that will require
the um the stabling people or people of
the site to maintain it and personally i
would like to see
a condition put on that the road is made
up to an acceptable standard i.e tarmac
for access
so that
mud and
stuff like that when it's wet it's not
transferred up onto the highways
sorry
chairman
i anticipate that the applicant is
equally responsible for their part of
the road they have perhaps a share in
that i think the speaker was going to
allude to those
true circumstances legally if he had
more time
but
what you have to be careful of is that
there's an existing use there
and it's just crossing the road as the
other speaker said so you'd have to be
trying to demonstrate that it's
essential that they make up the road in
the way you are because of some added
harm okay the problem is you can't look
up on the planning permission doesn't
mean to fix problems
um you've got to look at the problems
that are so severe
that are a direct cause of this
application different to the one or the
existing use that they've got now if you
i think tarmacking would be unreasonable
to tarmac a road properly you have to
have edging and curbing and you make it
up to quite a substantial standard a
high cost
what does happen sometimes is that
following construction developers
um fill potholes they put type one mix
in or whatever the only downside with
that is what was a hole and a puddle
yeah
where you put the fill in because you
raise the fill because it's to sink
under compaction you end up with a
sprawling puddle between the holes
you've just filled so so you end up with
this endless task of keep tipping type
one mix on until you get something
higher than road level like this you
know and it's it's basically
unreasonable
um to expect an applicant to do that to
a road surface
at some kind of specification which
isn't clear
so
you could ask for them to follow in the
construction to make good any damage
which would build on the condition that
was mentioned earlier about surveying
the road and
you know
doing a before and after effect
but you'd have to be very careful as to
the extent that you asked the applicant
to make that that surface good i think
tarmacking and and that is is too far
you'd probably end up with road planings
uh and type one fill or whatever it's
the best you could hope for for the
worst parts definitely not the whole run
of the street
recommendation on the table
subject to um set out on paragraph one
point one on pages eight point one to
eight point six of the report with a
revised condition 14 set out on the page
two of the addendum
uh this is for approval can i have
i i'll put the motion forward for
approval can i have a second to please
councillor fd
can i have a show of hands for approval
of this application please
can you
lower your hands please
can i have um hands up for
refusal sorry
are those four against sorry
thank you any abstentions
counselor stanley
so we've got uh
four
seven against two one
abstention thank you members thank you
very much for a good meeting and the mem
uh it is closed at i haven't got a close
song off watch 22 10. thank you very
much thank you for the members of the
public for staying so
coming
late